this video was made in partnership with
nikon healthcare a leader in scientific
imaging and tools you can learn more
about their imaging technology and
microscopy solutions by visiting the
link in the description
in labs around the world you can find
tanks like this one they are filled with
zebrafish who have received that name
for obvious stripe related reasons these
particular zebrafish are residents of
the national institutes of health where
they provide researchers with the means
to study disease and understand more
about how life develops and here thanks
to the power of fluorescent proteins and
microscopy we see the zebrafish in a
whole new palette lit up in electric
shades of blue and orange this image is
first and foremost discovery the result
of a scientific hunt for a series of
vessels inside the zebrafish whose
existence might help scientists
understand human diseases but we'll get
to that in a bit because what we can
also appreciate is that this image is
stunning there's the clarity and the
contrast of the colors the sense of
texture as the scales begin to overlap
you don't have to understand everything
going on in this image to find it
beautiful just like any art really
which is why it is perhaps not
surprising that in 2020 the scientist
who took this picture submitted it to
the nikon small world photomicrography
competition
and one
[Music]
the nikon small world competition began
in 1975
with the photomicrography contest
providing a showcase for all of the
spectacular imagery that many masters of
microscopes have observed and created
using whatever subject or technique that
suits them and in 2011 nikon added a new
video category called small world in
motion
every year nikon gathers a panel of
judges to go through the submissions and
decide on the winner and in 2021 that
panel of judges included me your trusty
journey to the microcosmos host hank
green
i was there as you might imagine not so
much for my technical expertise as i was
to get excited about and interested in
the stories behind the images and i said
yes
not just for the free camera that i did
get but also to have a couple of days to
sit around with true experts in their
fields and to get some real
behind-the-scenes insights into science
that you can't really get by reading
articles and i was not disappointed by
the insights of my fellow judges who are
true experts and were really lovely
people
[Music]
the 2021 winner of the small world in
motion competition was this
spectacular clip of symbiotic protists
that live inside of a termite's gut
taken and submitted by fabian j weston
from australia filmed with polarized
light and a microscope from the 1970s
you can see how much these organisms
resemble organisms that you have seen in
our episodes but these organisms have
managed to carve out a home for
themselves inside of termites where they
helped their host digest wood and other
plants
this is one of the transportive
experiences of microscopy the way that
one image can reveal a world that is
both so alien and unifying at once and
if there is an animal that has embodied
that dichotomy over and over again it is
the one we started this episode with
the zebrafish
[Music]
now on the one hand
it doesn't seem like we should be
finding a lot in common with a striped
minnow this is a fish that spawns eggs
when daylight breaks that has those eggs
fertilized outside of its body and that
will produce hundreds of offspring
through this method over the course of a
week
and their embryos develop really quickly
assembling a head tail and heart within
24 hours of fertilization so when you
hear all that
the daylight spawning the external
fertilization the rapid development you
probably would not expect to find much
common ground with the zebrafish except
that we do share common ground we share
about 71
of our genome with a zebrafish
and many of those genes are valuable
counterparts to understanding human
diseases
the combination of similarities and
differences make zebrafish an
extraordinary resource for scientists
as an embryo and larva the zebrafish is
transparent and with the right
combination of pigment mutations
scientists have been able to create a
ghostly translucent version of the fish
called casper
that clarity makes it much easier for
scientists to observe the inner workings
of the fish under the microscope
compared to you know much more opaque
animals like us or mice and since
zebrafish are easy to take care of and
regularly make embryos they provide many
many opportunities for researchers to
search for equivalence to our own selves
in the fish
in the case of the image we just showed
at the beginning of the episode what
researchers were pursuing was a series
of lymphatic vessels inside the
zebrafish's skull
in mammals these vessels maintained the
right balance of fluids in our nervous
system making them potentially important
for understanding diseases like
alzheimer's and being able to use
zebrafish to study these vessels would
be amazing except for one problem no one
had ever observed lymphatic vessels in
the skull of non-mammals no one that is
until daniel castronova and his fellow
scientists in brent weinstein's lab at
the nih
they used fluorescent proteins in
transgenic zebrafish to highlight the
lymphatic vessels bones and scales and
you can see those parts of the zebrafish
here the lymphatic vessels are shown in
orange the bones and scales are shown in
blue to take these images the
researchers anesthetized a juvenile
zebrafish and mounted it on agarose to
hold it still
then they used a confocal microscope to
divide and image the fish in layers it's
a bit like cutting the fish into cross
sections only there's no need to make a
physical cut the microscope creates
those cross sections through its own
optical methods the result is around 387
images that could then be stitched
together to create one final image but
this image is not just a 2d photograph
it is a three-dimensional reconstruction
creating a map of cells inside the
zebrafish that tells the researchers
which vessels are inside and outside the
skull this map revealed that zebrafish
have lymphatic vessels inside their
skulls moreover researchers can easily
do live imaging of these vessels they
can even see immune cells traveling
through those vessels
what the final product reveals is not
just something new and not just
something beautiful what this image
reveals really is the possibility we
continue to find in zebrafish and much
of this possibility is scientific a
future where experiments with zebrafish
contribute to a greater understanding of
disease
there is so much work that goes into
making images like this one and all the
other nikon small world submissions so
much careful thought and technique to
determine how to use biology and
technology at once and all of it hinges
on the microscope a scientific and
artistic instrument rolled into one that
has allowed its many masters to craft
visions of worlds that contain bits of
ourselves
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you again to
nikon healthcare for helping us make
this video if you want to learn more
about the imaging technology that helps
to create amazing microscopy like what
you saw in this video make sure to check
out the link in the description and if
you'd like to see more imagery and video
that blends science and art check out
the microscopy galleries at
nikonsmallworld.com i know i have spent
a lot of time there a big thanks to all
of the people whose names are on the
screen right now they are our patrons on
patreon patreon is a place where people
support the things that they think
should exist in the world and all of
these people have decided that they want
journey to the micro cosmos to exist in
the world and gosh darn it if we don't
agree with them so thank you all so much
we obviously could not do this without
your support if you would like to become
one of these people you can do that at
patreon.com journey2micro if you want to
see more from our master of microscopes
james weiss you can check out jam and
germs on instagram and if you want to
see more from us there's always a
subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you